[Music]
we love Disney weddings the flowers the
fashion in the food are second to none
we just can't get enough of these
over-the-top Affairs give this video a
big thumbs up if you love Disney romance
if this is your first time at the things
don't forget to smash that subscribe
button let's jump right into the 10 most
amazing Disney weddings of all time
Anita and Roger Anita and Roger had a
pretty epic Disney romance from the
moment they met it was faith their
beloved dogs Pongo and perdy seemed to
fall in love first the fuzzy pair
brought their human parents together for
a cold wet and angry first meeting from
that rocky start things really heated up
in front of the fireplace Anita and
Roger really warmed up to each other and
had a beautiful wedding it was a small
intimate ceremony held in a gorgeous
stone chapel just outside a rose covered
window they're spotted best friends had
their own romantic moment the beautiful
dogs made a meaningful commitment that
day a double wedding is a real treat
especially one with two such cute
couples we love this Disney wedding it
may not have been especially extravagant
but it was sweet and genuine weddings
aren't just about centerpieces and
lavish gowns at their heart weddings are
about love commitment and family
this ceremony focused on the love
between these humans and their dogs they
make a beautiful family soon both
couples will find themselves expecting
it's a beautiful love story no matter
which couple is your favorite Maid
Marian and Robin Hood Maid Marian and
Robin Hood shared an epic romance full
of adventure Robin was the charming
outlaw and Marian was the free-spirited
socialite their love was definitely
looked down on by society
none of Marian's family approved of a
thief who lived in the woods times were
so hard for the people of Nottingham he
were being taxed to starvation by a
selfish king Robin Hood was such an
important community figure his brave
work ensured his neighbors had enough to
eat during dark days when it was finally
time for him to get hit everyone got
involved the whole town must have been
so overjoyed to share this special day
this may be one of the most communal
weddings Disney has ever created even
the kids in town were in on the nuptial
bliss you've never seen so many cute
guests at one
it was definitely the break Nottingham
needed from all that doom and gloom the
couple was Wed in a beautiful stone
church the ceremony was officiated by
their dear friend Friar Tuck just
because it was a town event didn't take
away from the intimacy watching the
couple leave the ceremony was a magical
moment too they rode off into the sunset
in a beautiful carriage a just married
sign hung across the back as the perfect
final touch note in spirits
Belle and Prince Adam much like Maine
Marion and Robin Hood this wedding was a
community affair as well considering the
pitchfork wielding mob that stormed the
castle it's impressive that Prince Adam
turns his public image around it helps
that he no longer resembled an angry
water buffalo fell on Adams wedding date
didn't make it to the big screen but
there is an entire book about it Beauty
and the Beast Belle's royal wedding
covers every detail of the celebration
we get to see behind the scenes as Belle
Prince Adam and the palace staff prepare
for the big day Belle tries on her epic
wedding gown
it's a classic ball gown that sweeps the
floor every inch of the dress sparkles
like a diamond the gown is covered in
delicate rosettes they are her favorite
flower after all she looks every bit the
Disney Princess Bride
as she admires her gown she tells mrs.
Potts that she and the broom want the
whole staff to be guests at the
celebration Phil didn't specify who
would work the event in their absence
but the gesture is really sweet when the
big day arrives Lumiere had a surprise
for his beloved friends he invited the
entire village to attend the couple was
thrilled to share their special day with
her subjects and their friends Mulan in
Li Shan Mulan may be the fiercest Disney
Princess she had the courage to take her
father's place in war she trained hard
alongside men twice her strength she
never gave up and became a hardened
soldier when her company was in an
impossible situation
she kept cool she used quick thinking
and creativity to save herself and her
friends she ended up saving all of China
Mulan falls in love with her former
commander li Shang the two make a pretty
tough power couple in the sequel Mulan
and li Shang get engaged her family is
buzzing with excitement to welcome a new
son the pair is given a serious quest
from their
Emperor thereto escorting princesses to
be married to foreign princes on the
trip li Shang and Mulan are attacked it
seems likely shank is dead in her grief
Mulan offers herself to marry a prince
in order to save the unification Mulan
prepares for her wedding to the young
prince she looks absolutely stunning in
her traditional wedding garb just as the
marriage is about to be sealed li Shang
appears to save his beloved in what is
one of the most spontaneous and romantic
Disney weddings the two are Wed right
then and there Carl and le Disney have
made a reputation for itself for
creating epic royal weddings from white
horses and carriages to lavish feasts
nothing out des Disney there's one
Disney wedding that captured everyone's
heart with all the pomp and circumstance
while most Disney weddings are the
delicious ending to a fairy tale this
one was more down-to-earth in up shy
young Carl meets precocious Ellie the
two become friends immediately they grow
together and so does their love everyone
swooned as the pair dated their romance
was so sweet simple and genuine there
wasn't a dry eye in the house as Carl
and Ellie tied the knot their wedding
was small and intimate it didn't have
all the grandeur of a princess story but
it had all of the romance their love
spanned decades and saw them through
tough times instead of the wedding being
at the end of the story we got a unique
tale we got to watch Carl and Ellie's
entire relationship in marriage right
until the end
this wedding goes down as one of the
best in Disney history the marriage it
produced gave two people years of
happiness it was the foundation that the
rest of the story was built on
Cinderella and Prince Charming no list
of Disney weddings would be complete
without Cinderella's she was the very
first Disney Princess to get married she
had to set the standard for all future
royal weddings to this day any lavish
fairytale wedding is referred to as a
Cinderella wedding this grand affair was
nothing short of epic there was a
beautiful horse-drawn carriage pulled by
white horses the prints were a stunning
suit of white with regal gold trim
Cinderella was stunning in a magnificent
ballgown
into the ballgown sparkled like again
every detail from her veil to her
earrings was perfect as the happy couple
leaves the ceremony one charming moment
calls back to win the couple first med
running down the steps to the carriage
Cinderella loses her shoe once it's
safely back on her delicate foot the
couple is on their way as the carriage
pulled away
Cinderella's transformation from floor
scrubbing orphan to princess was
complete the carriage pulls away from
the wedding surrounded by cheering
subjects Cinderella really waves at her
adoring public as she rides off into
happily ever after jasmine and Aladdin
this is definitely a wedding saved from
the brink of disaster jasmine and
Aladdin had a whirlwind and somewhat
controversial romance the princess fell
hard for the common thief a lot of fans
weren't too thrilled that the
relationship started out based on lies
Aladdin definitely wasn't a prince and
didn't have the wealth he pretended to
flaunt after jasmine found out the truth
about her prince she chose to forgive
him that's pretty impressive not too
many people could forgive that kind of
deception in the sequel to Aladdin the
couple finally prepares to be married
the ceremony is almost ruined when
Aladdin's father arrives with his band
of thieves the gang of ruffians attempts
to crash the wedding by literally
ripping the palace apart once the
wedding finally happens for real it's
breathtaking the ceremony is lit with
dozens and dozens of candles the glow
adds to the romantic atmosphere jasmine
looks like a living work of art her gown
is modest yet stunning she looks as
perfect as a Disney princess should
Aladdin is equally decked out in Royal
garb everyone is swept away by the
emotion of the moment genie is
particularly choked up
Aladdin's long-lost father proudly
watches as his son gets married the
Sultan is ecstatic even Raja gets in on
the action he proudly carries Jasmine's
train as the couple leaves the altar
whose patches what are we trying to say
beggar no let's work with me here like
it we're much Ariel and Prince Eric
Ariel's love story spans two worlds for
impossible romance spans both land and
sea
Ariel was pretty obsessed with humans
even before she knew her prince existed
she spent her youth collecting all of
the human things she could find one
might argue that Prince Eric was the
ultimate addition to her collection
Ariel went to extremes to win her man
she gave up her tail her voice and her
life under the sea for a chance at love
Eric fell in love with the beautiful
stranger even though they couldn't speak
he overcame a lot of obstacles as Ursula
tried to tear them apart but their love
saw them through when it was finally
time for the pair to tie the knot they
breathed a sigh of relief after
everything they had been through it was
time for their happy ending
Ariel looked every inch the perfect
princess bride her gown was classic with
huge sleeves and a bell skirt her veil
was attached to an ocean-themed tiara
paying tribute to her past the wedding
was held on a beautiful ship to allow
Ariel's family to be there too this
princess had possibly the sweetest
father of the bride moment in Disney
history after forbidding her love with
Eric King Triton finally gives his
blessing the pair sailed off into the
sunset under a perfect rainbow Rapunzel
and Eugene Rapunzel and Eugene had one
of the most fun and personal weddings of
any royal Disney couple when you think
of princess weddings laughter and fun
aren't usually the first things that
come to mind this star-crossed pair had
a truly memorable and silly wedding day
that would go down in Disney history for
Rapunzel and Eugene it wasn't exactly
love at first sight most epic romances
don't begin with a frying pan to the
face Rapunzel definitely made an impact
on him once the swelling went down
feelings started to develop Rapunzel
began to see Flynn as a dreamer he began
to see her as a fighter the pair fell in
love on their quest to see the floating
lights that trip happened to reunite
Rapunzel with her parents she found her
real family after so long entangled ever
after the lovebirds get their special
day the wedding was beautiful but it
wasn't without a few glitches when you
trust a horse to be your ring bearer you
have to expect a little chaos Maximus
was very handsome carrying the ring
pillow right up until a yeast sneeze the
sneeze set off a series of wild events
that destroyed half of the kingdom and
most of the reception
that's a lot of hair she's growing it
out Tiana and Naveen Fiona and Naveen
hold a very special place in Disney
history they're the only couple that
have two weddings
Tiana definitely deserves to have a
double wedding she was so responsible
and hard-working her dedication to her
dream proved that she's perfect marriage
material like many couples their romance
wasn't love at first sight Tiana wasn't
the kind of girl who had her heart set
on marrying a prince all she cared about
was opening her restaurant and working
hard when she and Naveen find themselves
turned into frogs they have to learn to
work together going through the
challenges and struggles of the swamp
help them to see who each other truly
were taking the time to get to know each
other slowly turned into falling in love
the pair briefly faces being stuck in
frog bodies that doesn't stop them from
exchanging vows once the adorable little
frogs day I do Tiana is officially a
Disney Princess to parrot kiss and just
like that the spell is broken Tiana and
Naveen transformed back we get to live
the magic moment all over again as the
pair get married a second time in human
form the two have a beautiful church
wedding both of their families are
overjoyed to share this special day
which Disney wedding is your favorite
let us know in the comments below we
hope you enjoyed this look at these epic
Disney weddings don't forget to
subscribe to the things for even more
Disney fun see you in the next video
[Music]